hey guys what's up this is andrew for
joining sensors.com so in this video
guys i want to take a step back on amc i
want to discuss a major question which
is can a squeeze still happen so let's
get into it
[Music]
all right guys so like i said in this
video i want to go quickly through what
happened you know in the past year of
course i'm gonna analyze friday's press
action with saturday so yesterday's
press action for me see what can happen
i'm going to explain a little bit my
view
we're going to go through what happened
last year guys the whole year because a
lot of things happen and i want to
explain in this video why i have the
view i'm going to show you and what we
need to be looking at and yeah what is
the global situation for emc so just if
i take a step back once again guys i'm
on a daily chart daily time frame and i
wanted to explain a little bit more what
happened guys in january right because
this was the last time we almost had a
squeeze so okay i was analyzing uh amc
here as well and so here
you know the situation was much
different guys we didn't have the
massive squeeze yet uh i'm talking about
may everybody was you know i started to
cover him see around five guys it was
here you know probably in february
something like that
i'm not sure yes yeah probably in
february i started to cover emc and of
course i was bullish and since we were
here guys i was calling for a squeeze
and as you guys know those who were with
me at that time i was very accurate
about the levels this quiz happened like
you know following a lot of technical
analysis
tools like fibonacci projections
uh trend lines were respected it was
kind of squeezed that you know was
i would say easy to predict then we had
a lot of
troubles guys you know i was you know
hoping for this fifth wave this massive
fifth wave 235 you guys know it's the
level i'm talking about for very long
time and i was expect expecting this
level to be reached much sooner let's be
honest guys here i struggled a lot i
gave you a lot of false signals guys and
you know i need to you know to just
recognize the fact that amc technical
analysis is very very hard to do and
this is the reason why i want to come
back in this video and what happened
before so that you can understand how to
interpret what i'm gonna give you now
and so here yeah it was very hard and i
personally
got trapped at 44
i know that a lot of you got trapped
there as well maybe because of my videos
and i'm very sorry if you know some of
you lost money because of me i feel of
course a bit responsible
even if i'm not giving financial advice
guys it's only my view and you i know
that you guys you know take your own
decision in the end but i still feel a
bit responsible and you can watch the
videos i was uh posting at that time
don't only
watch the title guys because the titles
are always you know bullish because i'm
doing my part of the job you know my
part of the job as a amc youtuber is to
be optimistic to insist maybe more on
the positive scenarios but i'm always
giving you two scenarios guys all right
and because i i don't know what's gonna
happen you know you guys probably know
that but i want to insist on the fact
that nobody knows what can happen and
i'm always you know trying to use
technicals to show you how the market is
reacting to some levels i'm trying to
give you some support levels some
resistance levels but i'm of course i i
never know what's gonna happen exactly
but here
if you check my videos yes i was telling
you
that uh something would happen in
january you can check november october i
was saying that why because i had this
triangle right i had this triangle and i
was telling you that before the end of
the triangle so the end of the triangle
was in jan right and end of deck and i
told you something will happen of course
i was bullish of course i was expecting
it was on the upside of course here i
got trapped in this uh fake out which
was by the way respecting very weirdly
all the wood rules of a good breakout so
of course this market is manipulated as
well hedge funds know how to
lure
investors as well in those traps have
they of course you know participate in
creating those traps because it's easy
money for them but it's a dangerous game
they play because
apes are strong apes are
more and more in the world and if they
try too many times to create bull traps
at some point a bull trap will
uh transform in a massive short squeeze
for them so it's a dangerous game they
play but the the thing is that i told
you here that we would probably go on
the upside but that if we go on the
downside we would have
probably a massive move down and you can
check my videos once again don't read
only the title in all of my videos i try
to give you different scenarios because
you need to be prepared for both cases
and here
you guys know that we had this breakout
i was here in the plane i was moving
from hong kong to france so i didn't do
any video here but you can check the
video i did right after when i came back
to france and i told you guys that we're
gonna drop heavily all right and that we
would need time and i'm saying that for
very long time right i was always
drawing some things you know like that
and once again you can watch my videos
you can watch my discord dailies guys if
you just you know this is free guys on
my discord i share every day my levels
on amc
uh i try not to give a view too much
because it's very hard to know on the
daily timeframe what's going to happen
amc is easier to analyze on a weekly
time frame i mean you know to predict
bigger cycle moves the short term moves
are very very hard to predict i'm not
playing this game anymore i did for
quite some time and it was not easy at
all
but when you look at what i was saying
guys uh back in the time this was in
january we were at 20 i would i've
always said we're gonna go to 14.5 this
was my level for quite some time guys
and i was always drawing some things
like that you know
you can see here we're training at 18
and i was already saying we're gonna go
to 14.5 that we're gonna just you know
go make some ups and downs and uh
finally break out on the upside so this
is still the view i'm having guys okay
so this is still the view i'm having
once again the question i'm trying to
answer here is this quiz can still
happen and what i can tell you guys and
i uh brought you in the past to show you
what i was saying before i know that
some of you trust me because i'm giving
realistic targets uh 135 was very
realistic i think we could have gone
there guys in jan i mean in uh november
it didn't you know we were not far from
this massive squeeze to happen but you
know there were a lot of things that we
could not predict like the kovid that
you know the different variants whatever
for the cinema industry it was not good
for the global market it was not good so
the squeeze didn't happen but now what
i'm saying i'm going to bring you to my
conclusion i'm coming to it right now is
that we still have this trend line okay
and you can you can check where yeah i
didn't finish what i was saying at the
beginning but here it was the same thing
triangle okay so you never know where
on which side a triangle is going to
break but whenever you have a good
triangle with consolidation low volume
then a breakout is very often followed
by a move in the same direction okay
here it was true okay
here unfortunately it was true too you
need an increase in volume guys and by
the way guys if you don't want to wait
until this quiz happens to make money uh
grab my calls there's still 50
discount until tonight only guys if you
don't take it today you won't probably
never take it and in this course guys
i'm giving you a step-by-step method
that is working very well guys on any
stock of course mcnjimi are not the best
ones to do that but all the other stocks
the industries uh the methods i'm giving
you guys it's a step-by-step method for
beginners guys it's very easy to
understand it's what i've been doing
guys for so many years and it's just
generated consistent profits of course
it's not every month you're gonna make
money but at the end of the year
whatever happens usually you make money
if you follow the steps i'm giving you
guys and it's the best gift you can make
to yourself you're gonna find back your
investment in two months maximum three
months and if you don't like the course
guys you're fully refunded once again
it's a very good investment on yourself
and you know i know that you guys like
to trade amc but don't forget about all
the other stocks guess because i didn't
make money on amc guys in the past year
i mean the past six months but i made
money on the other stocks guys so just
don't forget
that's that here as well so let's go
back to amc so here
the thing is that now we have this
trendline
and
i don't know what's going to happen yes
we had a brutal move down on friday
minus eight percent i didn't see much
many news about that i i don't know if
you're gonna go to 12
then rebound or rebound right away then
go to 14 you know i don't know but what
i know is that it's gonna take time it's
probably gonna oscillate like that yes
for a couple of weeks
and
whatever the path we take load and up
add them low what's going to happen is
that on this stream line that we have
not tested for quite some time we're
going to have a selling rejection and
just
think about
your position guys i mean i'm i'm seeing
you know apes say they don't sell they
do sell they want to exit the trend it's
been a long time it's happening and for
this reason guys the squeeze is not
going to happen the first time we touch
this trend line the first time we're
going to touch it so it's around 30
right now it's of course going down with
time
uh there's going to be a selling
reaction probably you know some profit
taking maybe from those who bought here
uh some old long-term buyers would
probably maybe some back holders
exit as well some of the positions so
the first time we're gonna get here
we're probably gonna get rejected okay
that's usually what is happening when
the trend line has not been tested for
quite some time you can look what
happened here we came to this trend land
we got rejected we went there a second
time so then probably the same
phenomenon is gonna happen and there's
gonna be a trend line that we
for now it's 14.5 maybe it's gonna be
12. i don't know guys uh but there is go
there's going to be a trendline here on
the downside
let's say it's 14.5 let's say it holds
okay
that is going to act as support and
usually triangles they don't break at
the very end of it okay they usually
break before
at here at some point guys so that's why
i think it's gonna be in april may
something like that and it's what i'm
saying for two three months guys so i'm
still having the same view i don't know
what's going to happen between but i
know that between before april may
something
big is going to happen it can be in the
downside as well guys if it's on the
downside then we probably go back to
five
six
that's one scenario it would mean that
the global market is really not in good
shape that the war
between russia and ukraine is creating a
lot of troubles uh but it can also be on
the upside and this is the positive
scenario this is my preferred scenario
this is what i think can happen
uh because you can see the results of
amc are better the coveted crisis is
slowly being behind us they have a
positive not positive per share yet but
they're gonna have soon they have a
positive a big dm so earning before
interest depreciation and amortization
uh i saw that recently you can have a
look it's positive for the first time in
202
we they have a lot of cash in hands
people are going to go back to cinema if
the kobe crisis is really behind us so
they have a lot of good reasons to be
positive
for the coming year but and the option
market guys is very animated as well i'm
not gonna show you that guys here
because it's i mean i i will let you
know whenever i see something really
crazy we can just check the basic
information together
but to conclude on uh if a squeeze can
still happen guys of course yes if it
happens what can we expect from it
uh a bit the same thing for now guys uh
we can expect
we first need time because we need bag
holders to exit and we need buyers we
need to create the same sentiment that
was uh when we had the first quiz at 20.
i don't know if you guys remember but at
that time everybody felt the squeeze was
was coming for now it's not the case
that's why time will make things so in
april may we would need to assess the
situation again
check the option market for now the
option market is hot but guys it's the
old options that are hot all right the
95 strike on march 18
we have eight million shares guys on the
on the strike is going to expire okay i
can tell you it's not gonna get rolled
right away people are not gonna suddenly
buy 95 strikes on uh july maturity or
jan 23 because
it's not the time but whenever they're
gonna do it i'm gonna see it i'm gonna
let you know for now the option market
is to me
slowing which is in line with what i'm
saying guys is that we need time and
whenever we're gonna arrive here guys
we're gonna use the usual techniques so
we're gonna try to spot a breakout
and
volume increase this is what we want to
see guys okay once again this is exactly
the techniques guys that can be applied
on any stock
of course hedge funds know these
techniques but i mean if they play with
that in here i'm happy to get trapped
again i'm happy to jump in the train
play the squeeze again of course guys
you need to be prepared the way you do
that
i know you don't like to use stop losses
then maybe cool options are more adapted
because you know
uh this is how investment should be made
with you know always preparing both
scenarios okay because everything can
happen but if we have a breakout on the
upside guys and if the option market is
rebuilt so for now
as you can see the gtc is at two it's
not big guys the
synthetic short is one percent i know
that this is only the official numbers
so of course there might be some other
uh shares that i don't see some naked
shares uh even on the option market that
i don't see i'm using bloomberg data so
bloomberg is accurate but you never know
hedge funds might be hiding some
information to bloomberg so but what is
for sure is that this data
movement is giving me information so i'm
seeing for now one percent of synthetic
short total and taking into account the
puts and the calls and if this is
growing
to five ten like it used to be then it's
hot okay and for now it's not hot guys
you can see amc
okay we have a gtc at two guys we had in
uh
deck november when we almost squeezed
dtc at 3.5 okay so this is what we need
we are at two right now so we need time
uh once again i'm going to be here to
let you know guys uh it's not easy to
cover amc stock let's be honest guys
because this market is manipulated i
need to be here to be optimistic give
you know show you the good scenarios but
i'm also here to show you the bad
scenarios guys this is my role and i
know that you expect from me to maybe be
a bit more bullish because we need
youtubers like me for this movement to
you know grow stronger but not
uh every time otherwise it's just not
realistic and whenever it's gonna be hot
i'm gonna be you know very bullish again
for now i'm neutral guys i'm neutral for
the coming weeks and once again i'm
waiting for what's gonna happen at the
end of this triangle and like i've
always said guys when there is a
triangle there is always something big
happening so i don't know upside or
downside but i know that something big
is gonna happen around april or may and
that we're gonna see what is the
direction of this market so that's it
for me guys i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to floor see you guys